we got an amazing show tonight really
what was that all right oh it was one of
our cameraman Tony lays them that's Tony
the cameraman what's yeah hey what's uh
what's uh what's going on Tony I'm sorry
Conan one of my tweets is really blowing
up on the internet great congratulations
but what why don't why they get up
what's going on well I assume you're
referring to my tuxedo
balus I'm brooch and golden suitcase
yeah that's what I'm referring to you
exactly
well Conan when you hit Twitter pay dirt
you prepare yourself for a life on easy
street I'm rich
what do you mean your what do you I'm
sorry I just understand what do you mean
you're rich yeah like I said one of my
tweets is totally blowing up almost
200,000 likes check it out groove is in
the fart
that's your tweet grooves in a fart yeah
you remember that song by delight yes
Tony I do remember yet okay well that
song was called groove is in the heart
right yes so that got me thinking what
else rhymes with heart we get it Tony I
did that thing you do you know all right
Bart cart dark er far yeah okay listen
thank you for the insight into your
process but just because you got likes
and retweets it doesn't mean you're rich
means I'm rich now Tony you're not rich
no you know I'm rich they pay you in
tweet bucks I read about it in a
magazine I had a dream about okay look
Tony listen to me that's not how it
works
come on look at you you have tons of
likes and retweets and you're super rich
that's true but the reason I'm rich is
my grandfather invented mayonnaise no
problem pop-pop
your grandpa seems like a cool ghost
yeah yeah anyway Tony let's get this
sketch back on track here you're not
rich check your bank account
okay mr. bigshot I will check my bank
account Wow what's the balance there 38
bucks see Tony yeah this was a horrible
mistake and I will now go return this
tuxedo good night everyone
all right we'll see
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I got to return this tux aren't you
the man who tweeted groove is in the
fart yeah
well here's a check for 1 million
dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I had no idea we were in a move it was
quite an odyssey why not a CRO they
Labrecque we come back Bob Odenkirk
samples you in a second
you